[Musique]
ralentissements sur les routes mais
également trafic en partie interrompu
sur la ligne c du rer plusieurs stations
de métro ont également été fermés bref
difficile de se déplacer encore
aujourd'hui à paris qu'à me buttin fred
avec bazire sur le rer c des voix noyée
l'eau s'est infiltrée partout sur les
rails impossible pour les trains de
circuler tout le trafic est arrêtée
entre la gare d'austerlitz et de
versailles les stations de métro elles
aussi sont inondés à saint michel ou
encore à cluny la sorbonne
toutes les entrées sont fermés résultat
sur les autres lignes
depuis ce matin ça se bouscule sur ce
cas il faut attendre longtemps avant de
jouer des coudes pour entrer dans le
wagon compliqué pour les voyageurs
en c'est quand on part on sait pas quand
on arrive donc je pense que je vais
mettre une bonne heure et quart
peut-être plus c'était métro taxis bus
bref la totale
c'était un koh lanta urbain moi je vais
descendre la bibliothèque françois
mitterrand j'avais points de la ligne 14
pour rejoindre la gare de lyon et de la
gare de lyon je vais à la défense et la
défense je prends le train qui veulent
avait eu hier pour descendre à montigné
voilà des inondations qui s'ajoute à la
grève qui frappe la sncf son patron
guillaume pepy appel ce soir les
syndicats à reprendre le travail
par solidarité aux cours et ne serait ce
qu'un instant mettre son drapeau dans sa
poche et cette suspension je pense que
tout le monde devrait y réfléchir
sérieusement parce que c'est ça qu'il
faut faire au moins en ile-de-france et
en région centre
malgré cet appel les syndicats ont voté
la grève
enfin sur les routes toutes les voies
sur berges sont impraticables
elles devraient rester fermés au moins
jusqu'à l'ain
[Musique]